hallo ich möchte ganz kurz zwei sachen
ansprechen und zwar will ich mich da
recht kurz fassen weil ich hasse info
videos erstinfo videos wir alle mögen
sehr gerne schokolade deswegen habe ich
heute schokolade zum frühstück gegessen
wir fangen haben erste sagte aber die
ich kurz reden möchte weil es die sache
ist die zuerst stattfindet sind die
video days ich werde bei dem video days
seien allerdings wahrscheinlich nur am
achten also die sind für alle die es
nicht wissen sie sind am 17 8 und am 8
am siebten achten und am 8 8 sind die
video days in köln in der lanxess arena
und ich werde wahrscheinlich nur beim 88
da sein weil ich habe knapp noch im
urlaub bin eventuell denke ich mir im
urlaub so yao der urlaub scheiße ich
komme doch schon tag er ist aber recht
unwahrscheinlich das heißt wenn ihr mich
am 8.8 irgendwo in köln trifft in der
lanxess arena oder da im gelände oder
bei dem video dies könnte nicht gerne
ansprechen auf ein foto oder autogramm
ich bin da eigentlich nicht so und sagt
dann so öl gilt alle weg sondern nehmen
dann die zeit dafür dass ich euch dann
da das gäbe was ihr möchtet und ja
wahrscheinlich bin ich am 88 bei dem
video days vielleicht auch beim siebten
achten aber hundertprozentig ab 8
das reicht jetzt dazu ich weiß bisher
noch nichts von irgend eine
autogrammstunde ich weiß noch nicht ob
ich eine machen möchte ich es gibt auf
jeden fall keine poster von mir oder so
weil ich das nicht so cool finde aber
ich werde da sein zweite sache die ich
ganz kurz an sprechen möchte ist ein
event bei dem ich kran kraft l p midcap
david arien der hde cetera dabei sind
sonst war wenn ihr wenn ihr euch denkt
ja ich kann nicht zu dem video days
kommen weil da bin ich ganz toll
verplant weil da bin ich im urlaub oder
whatever dann hat auch unser netzwerk
was cooles vorbereitet und zwar ist das
ganze event clash of games hat es schon
bei instagram angekündigt normal in
einem video gesagt und zwar ist es so
eine dreistündige show oder länger oder
ja ich glaube meine so ein bisschen
länger im e werk in köln am 19 september
da sind krankhaft da wie vorhin schon
gesagt david hain
kev ist dabei lukas der rapper der hardy
und da werden wir alle zusammen im
ersten runde zocken und ihr könnt uns
live zu sehen und wir werden studio
spiele da machen irgendwie weiß nicht
wer bin ich oder whatever und wir werden
euch auf die bühne holen und alles
mögliche machen und autogramme geben und
auch noch mal fotos machen und und zeit
mit euch nehmen und alles da gibt es
verschiedene ticketpreise ich kenne ich
damit gar nicht richtig aus ich weiß ihr
ticket sind sehr teuer aber es tut mir
leid ich kann da nichts für ich weiß
selber dass es bei kindern jugendlichen
oder halt studenten so ist das immer
nicht so viel geld am start ist dass man
einfach so gerne ausgeben würde aber ihr
könnt euch dass er gerne mal anschauen
ist mir leid dass die preise so teuer
sind allerdings ist die miete dafür
teuer und müssen bezahlt werden und so
weiter und so fort
es tut mir leid das heißt wenn ihr sagt
er ich möchte euch unbedingt sehen dann
habt ihr da definitiv die möglichkeit
uns zu lagern und alles mögliche zu
machen allerdings wenn ihr wirklich
sauer das ist mir zu viel geld dann kann
ich das vollkommen nachvollziehen das
ist euch überlassen ich möchte euch dazu
nicht zwingen allerdings wollte ich euch
nur mitteilen dass ich am 19.9 im bag in
köln bin link dazu seine beschreibung in
die stage inc.com special auf gamestar
schwieriges war das heißt
zusammengefasst achte achte bin ich
hundertprozentig bei dem video days
siebter achter weiß noch nicht genau und
am 19 09 bin ich im weg wenn ihr der
tickets kaufen wollen findet den link
unten in der beschreibung wir sehen uns
in einem nächsten video wieder und bis
dahin würdig zu ergehen hoffe ich habe
dir noch in den wunderschönen tag bei
mir ist gerade am regnen
aber ich war gerade schon zähneputzens